we have a look at a question like this
okay I'm gonna do it two ways we would
do to it firstly I'm just gonna do it
the straight way that I showed you
before okay which is to multiply the
numerator and then multiply the
denominator this will work it will give
us the right answer okay but as you're
seeing a bit there's another way to do
this 9 times 5 6 times 10 is 60 okay now
this is correct the answer is 45 over 60
but we can simplify this a little bit
can't wait okay
you would think yeah Daniel okay you can
go you go straight to 3 over 4 if you
see 45 is a multiple of 50 and 60 is
also a multiple of 15 so if you divide
this one by 15 and you divide this one
by 15 you'll get 3/4 just like that
there okay however to get to that a bit
faster and to avoid these like if 45 and
60 they're not so bad but sometimes the
numbers are the numerator and
denominator Thank You ginormous right so
here's what I would recommend instead
rewind right go back to the original
question before you multiply anything
yeah do this simplifying step do it
first make the numbers smaller before
you multiply rather than doing it
afterwards okay so for instance I see 10
and 5 both multiples of 5 right so I
would replace this 10 with a 2 and I'll
replace the 5 with a 1 I can also do it
with these two alright what's the common
divisor 3 I've replaced this fit 3 and
this with 2 so now all I'm left with is
3 times 1 and 2 times 2 which is a lot
easier to compute ok quick question
you find when you change their numbers
can you also do that one their necks
which I know leaked on and I'd like you
to think of an example of why that is
draw it up and you'll see what happens
all right one last quick note or a sip
record just in case you could not
remember it's fine it's a funny way to
use very often or reciprocals where you
take a number and you switch the
numerator in the denominator you switch
the top I bottom so for example the
reciprocal of 3/4 would be 4 over 3 4
thirds one of the questions is what
happens when you multiply a number by
its reciprocal and no matter what number
you start with except for zero okay what
happens when you do the numerators
you're gonna get in this case 12 yeah
and this will also become 12 so be 12
over 12 which is 1 over 1 which is
always 1 whenever you multiply another
by its reciprocal you'll always get 1
except for 0 what's wrong with 0 yeah
number one zero times anything zero
secondly zero doesn't have a reciprocal
because then you'd be like divide by
zero that's a bit of a problem you guys
kill anyone